ein zwischen gummigeschosse fliegen
abgefeuert von polizisten diesen presse
stoppt die schüsse auf uns nur knapp
verfehlen sie den deutsche welle
reporter steffen siemens trotz
deutlicher presse kennzeichnung
wir haben keine regeln verletzt wir
hatten uns bei der national guard vorher
das ok besorgt dort unsere positionen
aufzubauen
als die dann ab zog hatte die polizei
hier nichts anderes zu tun als einfach
mal ein schuss abzufeuern
ein einzelfall von wegen landesweit
werden bei den protesten gegen die
rassistische polizeigewalt journalisten
bei ihrer arbeit behindert beamten
drohten seines team gar mit einer
festnahme
die bundesregierung fordert eine
aufklärung journalisten müssten ihre
aufgabe nämlich die unabhängige
berichterstattung ohne gefahr für ihre
sicherheit nachgehen können und
demokratische rechtsstaaten müssen beim
schutz der pressefreiheit aller höchste
standards an den tag legen
doch die hohen standards die scheinen
derzeit in den vereinigten staaten in
gefahr
beobachter zählen während der proteste
schon deutlich mehr als 100 übergriffe
auf medienschaffende reporter die sonst
neutral zwischen den fronten stehen
werden gezielt angegriffen
amerika arrangiert derweil auf platz 45
in der rangliste der pressefreiheit eine
besserung kaum vorstellbar
denn laut reporter ohne grenzen trage
us-präsident trump eine erhebliche
mitschuld an den jüngsten angriffen
denn die saat die donald trump mit
seiner medien feindlichen hetze mit
seinen ständigen beschimpfungen von
journalisten und medien gesät hat sie
geht jetzt auf polizei und
protestierende gehen gegen journalisten
realisten vor
auch linda tissot wollte berichten nun
kann sie auf einem auge nicht mehr sehen
der vorfall ist ein weiterer beleg dafür
dass aus rhetorischem hass brutale
realität werden kann
auch antworten gibt es für
pressevertreter immer seltener
nicht einmal wenn sie vor laufender
kamera festgenommen werden es ist eine
eskalation mit ankündigung
bei einer wahlkundgebung in dallas
letzten oktober hat der präsident der
uns ja gerne als volksfeinde bezeichnet
stimmung gegen uns auf der pressetribüne
gemacht 20.000 menschen buhten manche
haben uns wild beschimpft das ist
absolut okay aber wenn man dann ein t
shirt mit der aufschrift sieht baum sein
journalist einfach zusammen zu bauen
dann hört der spaß auf
die usa sahen sich einst als leuchtturm
der pressefreiheit doch mehr denn je
scheint genau diesel in gefahr